thank you baby and so on I think you're
cute as well I really do thanks man
honestly thank you yeah yeah in fact um
don't take this the wrong I'm not gonna
take it
I would you sleep with me is that what
you know I was gonna say that at all
that's [ __ ] weird okay yeah just
happened yeah yeah so I would never say
I was gonna throw out a scenario of how
I would [ __ ] you okay the only the only
scenario where we would find whatever
sleep with you and [ __ ] you okay all
right what you wanna hear it out
not really you would like to hear all
right if I had life term oh you mean
like a life term in terms of prison
sentence in prison yeah in prison right
but it says an automatic [ __ ] right
waiting for I'm in for armed you know
all kinds of my collar no white blue and
black all the call the college I would
have money laundering I would have drugs
a walk I wouldn't have jaywalk yeah well
yeah I would update for a little thick
parking tickets a little bit in there
right I was on although minimal stuff
that just built up right like fondling
like mannequins mannequin mannequin
mannequins but I thought they were
mannequin shopping mall I thought they
were mannequin but they were real human
it's not that kind of fun so somehow you
didn't get to go to a mental institute
so I have a light set life sentence and
what happens is in my fantasy okay
is is that I get my first my fan is my
fantasy my fan is my fantasy is my first
cellmate prison fan it's an older black
man who's more like a Morpheus all I
have to do every night have to hear him
like tell me like life analogies you
know man oh if this is like the night of
whatever I don't know I saw yeah they
never saw never saw I've really so I
guess maybe he said maybe he's like a
prototype what you say that archetype
archetype okay city says stuff like yeah
when the sea stops and the you know I
mean the Ben turns around you got to see
your back you know like the things I
don't understand
yeah and I go shut the [ __ ] up old man I
can't say you know Rachel thinks I'm not
racist yeah yeah true but you're my head
I'll be thinking it because you're in a
prison cell all day yeah yeah yeah yeah
at least [ __ ] me [ __ ] me I would say
that's no matter on the top bunk I can't
the government you know man the way you
know whatever yeah yeah but then I see
Dylan you know me at the lunch but his
his first day in no he's been around
he's he's in for armed actually um you
know making what do you call it when
they do armed
did you try to put diseases in the world
they make disease I was like anthrax
yeah he's like a guy that would not not
I'm not doing well I gotta like cover
myself and [ __ ] cuz I'm not joining any
like I wouldn't even know to join gangs
yeah you would even that no no you're
like it's X like CIA like ya know or
more I see more of a McVeigh in you oh
my god that's not good
McVeigh yeah you know like a city boy oh
man do that I think that you did that
you're just that type where the ray-bans
and so I see him at lunch right like I
go to the Morpheus black all black who
that who dad would I say who dad who
died he goes oh you don't want to you
know this tip that's Timothy McGovern
that's the name of the like governor
yeah yeah yeah that's your name
yeah really yeah what he employee tells
me everything about him right and I go
yeah he seems like a bad guy but then I
limp and I think about him make eye
contact Dylan don't make iconic I know
like you know one lunch
you know Morpheus goes hey what sit over
there but not like at your table but
like closer yeah the text to get a
better like angle now that people
respect you in prison
no for jaywalking no no they call me the
whole like my reputation of prison is
called they call me the whole I don't
know thinking of Shawshank Redemption
right now with like the redhead I'm
basically like just a wet gigantic hole
my butthole at this point right has been
intruded on and penetrated so much right
there it's almost like not beyond
prolapse like my stomach lining
keep in mind speaking out of my pot hole
is your tail is my tail yeah and the
people think that I have some sort of
mutation I go no that's just the inside
of his [ __ ] Wow yeah and then people
don't worry about it because it's a good
thing to hang on to when you're [ __ ]
just hang on to the ends of my you know
perhaps but right thank you right and
they just like that sucks
yeah they shake it and just wet it's a
wet everywhere I mean it's okay so
you're sitting at a table next to him
you're at a table so we're at the table
next to him anyway right oh yeah by my
butthole doll like my prolapse butt off
till it's not
because I beg dude how is this guy still
alive he's walking around has one
stepping on his prolapsed butthole are
you like a rattlesnake snake when like
when you flirt does it also forget the
fantasy so maybe I wouldn't even notice
that you wouldn't notice he's flirting
he's rattling yeah yeah maybe I don't
have my glasses on and I'm just like why
do you have a cloak on yeah so one day
you trip you trip you're like you have
your tray right and you trip over my
tail accidentally a purpose I don't know
you know me but that's how we mean you
trip over my prolapsed ass like a
meet-cute no I don't have my glass and
then I do the war drums warden some
favors yeah I enter uh you know what
what's that the bull riding with every
year our mechanical yeah we all know we
have a real bull riding competition yeah
we go against other like prisons oh so I
you know I long as yard but yeah rodeo
like a rodeo yeah so every year there's
like a rodeo with prison prison right
and I bunked here and I'm very good I
get gold
every time the best yeah and one day I
just got listen that guy Timothy
McGovern jr. is there any way that I
could be cellmates with them is again
nobody wants to be sold to that
shit-eating [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I don't
know you look like oh yeah right and
then that's how we do it one night you
know we just we have burnout roommates
and cellmates and then um I think and
late no this is what happens it's not
done yet though 3:00 in the morning up
we're both pretending we're sleeping
giggles cute yeah
if you ever say good night good night
that's cute right there now all of that
I hear the rattlesnake oh no no this is
my rattlesnake
I play Bop It yeah yeah oh no you have
one hand on your dick jerking off and
you're jerking off my prolapsed [ __ ]
oh my god it's just like a double like
yeah I mean I want to add more I want to
say yeah I want us to say goodnight to
each other and I want to put my glasses
down but they fall off of my little
bedside table oh no my glass is broke
and you're like oh oh let me fix that
all right polish them or something or
maybe you need to take out your prolapse
and like it's so wet it's like rag you
need a reason to fall in love yeah yeah
I see you start helping me in ways that
I couldn't tell myself I'm sorry man how
you I apologized or yeah yeah so anyway
but you know what that would never
happen cuz we're not criminals and I'll
something okay so it's fine but it's
your fantasy it is my I appreciate that
man somebody's got to do a cartoon of
that right now that's already have some
animator doing someone was already
drawing that like as you were saying it
yeah
[Music]